So Yesterday concluded the first leg of
my what is a woman College screening
tour will be back on the road in a
couple of weeks fittingly our final stop
on this portion of the trip was the most
eventful I would say as I had previously
reported on this show the antifa cell in
Houston had promised to show up and um
shut the event down which is at the
University of Houston meanwhile far left
far left activists on campus had been
working on the University within the
university to cancel the event before it
even began but the event happened anyway
with hundreds of students waiting in
line a line stretching around the block
to get into the screening of our film we
packed an auditorium which unfortunately
could only hold a fraction of the people
who wanted to get in I'm not going to
say that what is a woman is the first or
only documentary to sell out College
auditoriums across the country but it is
uh certainly in a small Club I think but
while large crowds gathered inside there
were large though still significantly
smaller but crowds of protesters outside
who came together to voice their
strident objections to truth and reality
they attempted several different tactics
to I guess scare me away earlier in the
evening they stood in a line and in a
very direct sort of way they chanted
about what they want let's listen to
that
[Applause]
[Applause]
no
[Applause]
what do we want yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
so I think they want me out is what I'm
getting from that I like it Trails off
at the end and they get kind of lazy and
then they just at first what do we want
wall shout what do we want it now and
then that's too much effort so then at
the end it just turns into now now now
um it's a subtle message anyway but I
think I picked up what they were trying
to say I think I did
soon there were various speakers who
arrived with bullhorns to fire up the
crowd and lay out their indictments
against me here's one who describes all
the many ways that I have invited
violence against the trans community
started last week organizing a peaceful
process to get that supporters take both
transphobic rhetoric and I am proud to
see how far this has grown in this short
time for those who are not aware some of
the things that Walsh has said to invite
violence and hatred addicts the trans
Community include calling the supporters
to actions against Boston Children's
Hospital resulting on supporters
threatening a children's hospital with a
bob
Vanderbilt University Medical Center
resulting in the hospital suspending
gender affirmative care because of this
and other comments it's important that
uses cougars show up and say loud and
proud that we as students do not support
this
uh it was my inflammatory language that
resulted in Vanderbilt suspending their
child mutilation program evidently my
words are so scary that the hospital
simply bent to my will out of sheer
Terror and fear now I would like to
think that I am that intimidating and
Powerful I wish that was the case but uh
in fact that's not the case they
suspended their gender affirming care
quote unquote program because they could
not defend or Justify mutilating
children after those practices had been
exposed so that's how that's actually
how bad this stuff is that um all we had
to do was point it out and say look what
these people are doing and within a few
weeks they just stopped doing it you
know that's a that's like a pretty good
indication that someone is doing
something wrong where uh you know if
they're doing it and all you have to do
is point to the fact that they're doing
it and they stop doing it pretty good
indication that it's wrong indeed the
fact that they stopped doing it
actually proves that I was not using
inflammatory language they admit in
their letter to lawmakers announcing
that they're pausing the procedures that
my report was correct and they in effect
admit it because they they say they I
mean they had to have been performing
gender transitions on minors in order to
pause them it would seem
there was also this speech that I
enjoyed from another protester though I
feel a little bad that Stephen Crowder
and Andrew Tate catch some Strays here
for no reason but here's what she says
[Applause]
he could get away with coming to the
most diverse University in Texas
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah but
but I did get away with it I mean I I
thought I could get away with it and I
did I got away with it and it was great
I not only did exactly what you didn't
want me to do but I had I had fun while
doing it it was a lot of fun
yet still really think about the
phrasing here I'm gonna just skip over
the part where I'm a cockroach the
Cockroaches that have she was attempting
a metaphor there she's trying to get
poetic but cockroaches that have crawled
out of the dirt of hate to spread their
you know let's put that aside uh the
phrasing that that actually disturbs me
a little bit more is um he thinks he can
get away with this I mean like get away
with what exactly
existing speaking saying things
expressing a point of view
much is revealed about the leftist
mindset just from that one statement I
would say anyway the crowd outside grew
more and more Rowdy as the night went on
police had to arrest at least I think at
least one person as far as I know
when the speech concluded uh the mob
stood outside cussing at and harassing
the audience
as they left the building and uh and
there's a lot of videos there that a lot
of fun you can go watch because you know
my audience I'm very proud of them the
way they handled it they started
chanting let's go Brandon back so that
was great there are also some some early
on earlier on before the speech there
were some counter demonstrations of
people standing and and praying saying
the rosary while these satanic lunatics
scream at them you just as always you
see the contrast there and you can kind
of decide whose side you want to be on
but they then the protesters stood
around for a while longer even after all
the the crowds had cleared out I was
gone and they stood around around for a
while longer chanting various slogans
including this one
yeah they ran out of slogans by the end
of the night they did nothing left and
so they were left with that for some
reason I got to tell you that uh I I
derive a lot of pleasure from the fact
that at this point when the crowds were
screaming F Matt Walsh over and over
again I was already back at my hotel
sitting at the bar with a glass of
whiskey so there could not be anything
more impotent than crowds screaming in
protest against an event that already
happened while the guy they're
protesting is relaxing at his hotel out
of earshot
though they did attempt to do more than
simply scream uh outside I should say
I'm told by yaffe that
leftist activists on campus had been
sort of plotting to sabotage the event
by infiltrating the audio visual team
that's running it behind the scenes you
know amazing doing something with the
live stream or doing something with the
uh with the audio in the auditorium it
seems that one of them actually tried to
execute this plan the daily wire reports
this morning quote those trying to watch
the young America's Foundation live
stream of Matt Walsh's University of
Houston speech Thursday night were met
with an unavailable video and leftist
students student employees are being
blamed yaffe wrote following the event
that it believes it is likely that
student employees who opposed Walsh's
speech disrupted the live stream part of
the speech was seen on yes YouTube page
but poor audio made it impossible here
what Walsh was saying the live stream
later became completely unavailable
quote one of the student workers Kai Lai
was in communication with members of a
leftist coalition called stop
transphobia at uh and shared that she
would be working behind the scenes after
yaffe became aware of the student
student workers posting she was removed
from the event and a bomb sweep was
conducted this according to Nick Baker
assistant editor for yass the new guard
according to Baker several student
workers were required by the university
to remain on site for the event and had
access to yeah streaming equipment in
the hours before Walsh's speech earlier
in the night a person protesting event
was wrestled to the ground and
handcuffed by police video of the
incident showed the mass protester who
had made it inside the event venue on
the ground and surrounded by five police
officers who were attempting to arrest
him the protester appeared to be
carrying a small transgender flag that
ended up on the ground beside him so
they couldn't get in the room
but it looks like they were able to mess
with the live stream and uh so they so
they did that no big deal really there
are three other live streams from the
what is Woman tour available in the apps
YouTube page there will soon be several
more
besides the live stream is secondary the
most important thing is the event itself
like the physical event which none of
these screaming lunatics were able to
prevent or derail despite their many and
varied attempts
they were in the end powerless
and this is something that I want
the protesters at this and any
forthcoming universities to understand
but of course I will do precisely what
you don't want me to do and say what you
don't want me to say and there's there's
nothing you can do to stop it
you are powerless
and that's something you just have to
deal with
I know that you're accustomed to making
demands and having your demands met
but that's not the way it's going to
work this time okay I want you to know
how little your feelings
mean to me
I I want you to know that literally
nothing you say has any effect or makes
any impact I want you to know all of
that
so so so so often in your life you know
you you stomp your feet and you cry and
you get results and that's how you get
the results but I want you to know that
it's not going to work that way here
and I want you to know all of that
because it's a learning opportunity for
you
it really is it's character building I'm
trying to help you I want to help you
it's evident that most of you didn't
have fathers who would teach you this
lesson didn't have fathers at all in the
home that's extremely obvious
and so I'm trying to stand in the void
for you
you need to be able to cope with the
fact
people have ideas that differ from your
own you need to be able to make peace
with that reality
or don't make peace with it honestly I
don't give a damn it's your problem
either way my only point is that it's
good for you to encounter a situation
every once in a while where your cry
bully tactics just don't work
and that's especially the case here
because it's not just that I have
differing ideas from you
it's the it's that the ideas I'm
expressing
are simply true
self-evident obvious
okay you aren't just protesting
different ideas this is not I'm not
sitting here saying that you need to uh
the diversity of viewpoints you need to
accept the diversity of viewpoints I
mean you should be able to accept that
but that's not even what we're talking
about here
you are protesting the truth
that's what makes us all so pathetic and
disturbing
there have always been protests on
college campuses there have always been
differences of opinion
but you're trying to protest and silence
the truth
that's the issue
and to call for the suppression of Truth
is insane and tyrannical
you are tyrants
pathetic ineffectual laughable tyrants
but tyrants all the same
and that'll do it for us today uh thanks
for watching have a great weekend
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign